y empezó a trabajar con el padre de
trump el trump desde hace casi medio
siglo que es el jefe de finanzas de la
organización de trump se declaró no
culpable de los 15 crímenes financieros
de los que lo acusa la fiscalía general
de manhattan sus abogados dicen que van
a disputar estas acusaciones en la corte
si los cargos se comprueban eso podría
sin embargo significar decenas de años
en la cárcel para western break que ya
tiene 73 años situación que ha hecho que
varios abogados estén cuestionando si el
financista de los trump se mantendrá
fiel al ex presidente o terminará
cooperando con la justicia para tratar
de terminar sus días en libertad al
respecto el presidente el expresidente
trump dijo que esto se trata de una
cacería de brujas y que las acusaciones
terminarán dividiendo aún más a eeuu
hay que mencionar que trump no ha sido
acusado pero esto podría generar un
costo reputacional bastante grande para
sus empresas